welcome to the hugging face task series
in this video we will take a look at the
text summarization task
summarization is a task of producing a
shorter version of a document while
preserving the relevant and important
information in the documents
summarization models take a document to
be summarized and output to summarize
text
this task is evaluated on the rouge
score it is based on the overlap between
the produced sequence and the correct
sequence
you might see this as rouge 1 which is
the overlap of single tokens and rouge 2
the overlap of subsequent token pairs
rouge n refers to the overlap of and
subsequent tokens
here we see an example of how overlaps
take place
an example dataset used for this task is
called extreme summarization
this data set contains text under
summarized versions
you can use summarization models to
summarize research papers which would
enable researchers to easily pick papers
for their reading list
for more information about the
summarization task check out the hugging
face course